what's up reject nation it's your boy
John coming at you for just a second
here on Thanksgiving little throwback
Thursday just want to say hey want to
say thank you guys for watching thank
you guys for commenting liking disliking
anything really thank you for coming to
this page for sticking with us really
appreciate I've really been enjoying
this ride you know it's the first time
that Greg and I have been at this a
hundred percent this is both of our main
drive our main thing right now and it's
been really fun so thank you guys I need
to turn my phone on silent I also want
to say a big thank you the folks over at
think Jam our friends over there
Maribel janessa Tom Mandy all you guys
who we've been working with this
actually was possible because of them
and the fine folks at Fox Home
Entertainment - they've been really cool
to us this year giving us some cool
opportunities especially with American
Horror Story which you know I am
thankful for because I am a big horror
fan so yeah I just want to share this
with you this is something we did about
a month ago at the end of October didn't
get to put it up at the time just
because it was so much going on October
was was it was good it was busy but it
was also busy so uh this felt like an
appropriate throwback Thursday
unfortunately Greg was not able to join
us for this but our friend and need a
star as well as a team jab eco at BK
Anna Chara Kirk were there as well we
got to go down to a Universal to do some
cool stuff with the Halloween Horror
Nights crew and I thought you guys might
like to see that here so I'm Big Ups to
those scare actors a couple of whom I
know what's up Ashley big ups to the
team again overthink jam the team at
Halloween Horror Nights the team over at
Fox Home Entertainment Big Ups to you
guys whether you're with family today
celebrating Thanksgiving having a
friends giving out helping the less
privileged out learning perhaps about
our indigenous cultures whatever you're
doing today I hope you're having a good
day like seriously thank you for for
sticking with us and we've got a lot
more cool stuff plans so until then my
name is Jon enjoy
[Music]
have fun
[Music]
I love
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
the camera never stops no matter what
anybody says even if I tell you to stop
keep rolling you got it
you